♪ ♪ ♪
- Les arbres sont
d'extraordinaires machines
à purifier l'air. Sans arbres,
les villes étouffent.
Mais au printemps, comme
toutes les plantes à fleurs,
ils se reproduisent en relâchant
beaucoup de matière allergène
en très peu de temps.
ALAIN PAQUETTE, Chaire recherche
sur la forêt urbaine, UQAM
- La canopée, c'est important.Çe
qui sont très positifs et dont
on a besoin au niveau
de notre santé, mais il y en
a un qui est négatif,
c'est la production de pollen.
- En ce moment, il y a du pollen
partout dans l'air de Montréal.
C'est normal, la Ville préfère
planter des arbres mâles, qui
produisent du pollen et tolère
moins bien les arbres femell
qui ont le défaut de recouvrir
les trottoirs et les rues de
samares, de fruits et de noix.
- Pour répondre à cette
intolérance-là, on a commencéncé
à planter des clônes ou des
variétés qui sont dites
stériles, Mais la réalité, c'est
que la grande majorité d'entre
elles ne sont pas stériles,
elles sont mâles, donc elles
produisent quand même des fleurs
mais seulement des fleurs mâles,
qui donc produisent du pollen.
Alors on a remplacé un problème
d'esthétisme ou d'intolérance
par un problème de santé
publique.
- On estime en effet qu'un
Montréalais sur cinq souffre
d'allergies saisonnières,
que la moitié d'entre eux
ont des symptome sévères et que
la période d'allergies s'allonge
d'année en année.
Dre MARIE-JO OUIMET, Institut
national santé publique Québec
- Non seulement la saison des
pollens est allongée, mais
leur potentiel allergène aussi.
Les pollens eux-mêmes vont
causer plus d'allergies,
puis des allergies plus sévères,
en raison des changements
climatiques, mais aussi des
interactions avec d'autres
polluants atmosphériques,
comme le CO2.
- Pour aider ceux qui souffrent
d'allergies, il faudrait un
sytème de prévisions de pollen
plus fiable, dit le chercheur.
- Il existe des guides,
heureusement, et il existe
des municipalités qui font
des efforts et qui se basent
sur ces guides-là pour prendre
des décisions. Malheureusement,
selon qu'ils prennent un guide
ou un autre, ils arrivent à une
conclusion qui est totalement
opposée, qu'une espèce va être
allergène ou qu'elle le sera pas
du tout.
- À preuve, cette étude récente.
Elle évalue le risque
d'allergies à Montréal à partir
de neuf guides botaniques
différents. Résultat :
selon le guide utilisé, le
risque d'allergie à Montréal est
soit très élevé, soit modéré
ou soit très faible. Pour Alain
Paquette, c'est le signe qu'il
faut refaire nos devoirs.
Ce que vous nous dites, c'est
qu'on ne sait à peu près rien,
finalement, alors qu'on pensait
le savoir.
- Oui, sauf exception, comme
je le disais, les bouleaux par
exemple, on a de bonnes idées
qu'effectivement, ils sont
des problèmes, ils posent des
problèmes d'allergies.
Alors essentiellement, les
espèces qu'on plante en ville,
on les connait pas du point
de vue de leur potentiel.
- L'an dernier, son équipe a
installé 25 nouvelles stations
de captage de pollen sur l'île
de Montréal, qui n'en comptait
qu'une seule. On va faire
l'analyse génétique des pollens
afin de pouvoir distinguer,
par exemple, de quel type
d'érables ils proviennent.
ARAH TARDIF, membre,
laboratoire PaqLab, UQAM
- C'est une nouveauté, ça a été
rarement fait dans le monde.
Donc le but, c'est vraiment
d'identifer les pollens au
niveau de l'espèce.
- On recrute également des
dizaines de volontaires pour
faire un lien direct entre leurs
périodes d'allergie et le type
de pollen qui les affecte.
- Quand on prévoit que la hausse
de pollen va être significative
et engendrer des symptômes
sévères, on pourrait à ce
moment-là pouvoir avertir les
individus plus à risques, plus
susceptibles, pour qu'il
puissent mieux se préparer.
- L'année prochaine, la
recherche va s'étendre aux
villes de Québec, Sherbrooke et
Chicoutimi. Mais Alain Paquette
propose déjà des solutions.
- La première chose à faire,
c'est de diminuer les
proportions relatives de chacune
des espèces et éviter d'avoir
des espèces qui sont abondantes.
Parce qu'on sait que même si
on est allergique à une espèce,
il en faut quand même une
certaine quantité, de pollen,
avant qu'on développe une
réaction allergique.
Donc si on diminuait l'abondance
des espèces en les répartissant
mieux, on gagne sur tous les
plans.
- Les résultats de la recherche
devrait être disponible dans
deux ans.
ICI Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon